so there's this interesting
moment when that first caveman that
first capitalist
drew a line a circle in this cave and
said you know this is mine
you could say it was free to be claimed
at the time he claimed it
but it's an interesting moment
when uh asset becomes an asset
when space time as you're referring to
it becomes something that's now
can be possessed by a human being is
there something
special about this moment because it
feels like
first of all in terms of space and time
it feels like there's a lot of available
space-time yet to be claimed so if we
just look at like the universe right
we're talking about there's a funny
thing with the with elon musk and mars i
think they s
sneaked in there for spacex that uh
nobody on earth has any authority on
mars or any
this is a very interesting question it
seems almost like humorous at this time
but
perhaps not perhaps there'll be sections
of space
not just on planets that are going to be
even fought over
so is there something special about this
moment because
in discussing sort of violence and
respect for property
it feels like this is a special moment
because
uh ultimately conflict arises when you
make claims on a particular territory
it's you know it's not always in
conflict where people say
when you look at hitler or something for
example his claim would be
in many of the lands that he attacked
and invaded
that this is ultimately this has always
belonged to germany
so is there something you could say as
to like
what it means to own an asset or a
property
yeah so in the ancient days of hunters
and gatherers
we could say that property was mostly a
loyal title
which meant it's just whatever you can
defend right so if you've got
knives and daggers and satchels and you
know maybe some pelts
you've hunted whatever you can hold and
defend
is yours that's and and there's not like
there's a government to appeal to
you know you're just sort of a free
agent operating in the wild
defending the assets you can protect on
you more or less
um and what really
changed the nature of property is when
we get into the agricultural age
so there there's a big flip where we
went from just
foraging and hunting all the time
constantly moving trying to stay alive
to deciding we're going to settle here
we've figured out how to cultivate crops
we can create
uh you know we can increase the
population because you can we can
harvest more energy from the sun
and we can establish a longer term
civilization what happens
in that transition is that we begin
creating economic surplus
so for the first time in history we have
you know green
stockhouses of grain to defend or maybe
meat or cattle or
whatever it is we're creating we now
have savings
and it's at that time when
government emerges as well because once
you have savings so you have an economic
surplus you have something that
other people want to steal right this
this one thing we'll touch on a lot
today is people always want something
for nothing
there's always people always seeking the
path to get something for nothing and i
think that drives
a lot of our decision making and it
actually encourages us to be innovative
in a lot of ways right we're trying to
um it's you could say it's our laziness
it's helping us be inventive in a way
we're trying to accomplish greater
results with less efforts over time
but we can cross that line
in seeking something for nothing where
we start to violate the life liberty and
property of others
and that's where we shift from kind of
capitalistic society to
something more communistic and
so that's what government is it's a
protection producing
enterprise for the economic surplus
generated
by a trading society so when people
begin to trade
uh they create what's called the
division of labor
which is a very common economics term
basically means
you're better at making hats i'm better
at making boots
if you and i you specialize in hats i
specialize in boots and we trade we've
created a positive sum game
where you and i both benefit so we
become collectively more than the sum of
our parts
through trade and that's why human
beings do trade because we become more
energy efficient as a result we create
more outputs per unit of input
and you can think of government in that
respect if we're looking at it maybe in
a tech sense that
the economy is the trade network that
generates wealth generates innovation
generates all this whole lap of luxury
we live in today that we've inherited
from our
forebears is from the market it's not
from a government
the government is the network security
if you will
so we're we're paying expenses to a
vendor to protect
peace to preserve life liberty and
property in that network
so that we can have you know when
there's inevitably disputes over private
property
we can have non-violent dispute
resolution in the rule of law
um and we can have a reasonable
expectation of of being able to conduct
commerce without violence
the problem has been that the protector
tends to you know they're in a
monopolistic position
we'd say they tend to start abusing that
position
to obtain property for themselves again
trying to get that something for
nothing when you control you know you
are
the security guard for the economy
the first thing they tend to monopolize
is money because if you can control the
money you're effectively controlling
people their energy
their perceptions and that becomes a
you know particularly through inflation
becomes an avenue to get something for
nothing
and that you can just print more money
that everyone else is forced to
sacrifice their time and energy to
obtain
what are your thoughts about anarchism
so um
i talk quite a bit he'll be here in a
few days actually michael malus
about ideas of anarchy and his idea
or the idea of anarchists is that any
amount of government
will eventually become the very kind of
thing
that you're referring to so there's
almost no way to have a government
that doesn't then try to monopolize
power
money and all those kinds of things do
you think it's possible to have a
government
to run that spectrum of like anarchy
maybe
libertarianism i'm not sure how exactly
the spectrum goes but where you have a
small government that protects the
liberty and property rights and
those kinds of things and doesn't expand
to then also control
the the monetary system and all those
other uh
i agree agreed completely it was not
possible
until satoshi nakamoto so for the first
time in history we have a money
that cannot be monopolized cannot be
corrupted
cannot be changed cannot be weaponized
frankly
our current monetary system is
weaponized by those who can print money
against those who cannot
um and i think
when you have you know at the heart of
every modern economy which even we could
say the us
we pride ourselves as free market
capitalists you know we out competed
communism in the 20th century
we think that this is the superior model
um
most business people will tell you that
the free market is
the best allocator resources all of
these things but what we have at the
heart of every modern economy including
the us
is an anti-capitalistic institution
which is the central bank
the temptation to monopolize money
throughout all of history has been too
strong for anyone to resist
so any even benevolent quote-unquote
dictators that have taken over
many dictators have inherited say an
inflationary regime
where society is coming apart because
someone was clipping the coins or
someone was printing too much money
and they'll commit to going back to a
hard money standard so they'll keep
society
on a gold standard for instance such
that they cannot violate
um the money to benefit themselves
but inevitably over time because it is a
political
institution there's an incentive there
right for for again to get something for
nothing to spend more
than you're making through tax revenues
and
with that incentive people typically
ultimately end up pursuing that
inflationary path
you